360 حصريًا مع مقاتل سابق من
مجموعة فاغنر الذي انشق كما
تعلم، مجموعة فاغنر هي قوة مرتزقة
يديرها يفغيني باغوسيان، أحد القلة الروسية
المقربة من فلاديمير بوتين،
وقد وصفت الولايات المتحدة فاغنر بأنها منظمة إجرامية عابرة للحدود الوطنية
شاركت بشكل كبير في الحرب.  في أوكرانيا،
تم تجنيد أعداد كبيرة من
السجون الروسية. وتنسب فاغنر الفضل إلى
المكاسب الأخيرة في المناطق المحيطة بباكمود.
وكانت هناك الكثير من التقارير عن
الوفيات بين المدانين سيئي التدريب
والتجهيز لدى فاغنر، كما تفيد التقارير بأن
أولئك الذين رفضوا القتال أو حاولوا
الهروب يتم إعدامهم.  إنه بمثابة تحذير
للآخرين، حيث تم إعدام أحد مقاتلي فاغنر الذي انشق
إلى القوات الأوكرانية ثم تم إعادته
إلى روسيا كجزء من
تبادل الأسرى أمام الكاميرا
بالمطرقة الثقيلة، والآن يدعي رجل يدعى
أندريه ميدفيديف أنه انشق
عن مجموعة فاغنر.  عبر إلى
النرويج وتم إطلاق سراحه للتو بعد أن
أجرى مسؤولون نرويجيون مقابلات معه
ويأمل في الحصول على اللجوء هناك. قضى أندريه
وهو يتيم أربع سنوات في
السجن في روسيا بتهمة السرقة قبل
الانضمام إلى مجموعة فاغنر ويجب أن
نلاحظ أن خدمته في فاغنر تم تأكيدها
من قبل زعيمها  لقد تحدثت إلى أندريه
ميدفيديف قبل البث
إذا كان بإمكانك التحدث قليلاً عما كان عليه الحال في
المعركة في ساحة المعركة مع
السجناء، كيف كانوا، كيف تم
استخدامهم، ما هي التكتيكات، كيف كان الأمر
كما
كنا؟  "لم نتلق أي خطط تكتيكية، لقد
حصلنا للتو على أمر للاستيلاء على
موقع العدو
وكان علينا أن نتوصل بأنفسنا إلى خطة خطوة بخطوة
لكيفية تنفيذ ذلك، وكانت مشكلتنا هي
التأكد من تنفيذ الأمر
قلت في الماضي إنك رأيت
قوات فاغنر يتم إعدامها بسبب
عصيان الأوامر. إن
مثل هذه الحالات الدقيقة تحدث في كثير من الأحيان، وكان هناك
سؤال حول كيفية إقناع
المجندين الجدد الذين وصلوا إلى الخطوط الأمامية
وشاهدوا ما يحدث هناك
وقرروا ذلك.  لا يريدون القتال من أجل المضي قدمًا
والقتال، فسيجمعون
أولئك الذين لا يريدون القتال
ويطلقون النار عليهم أمام الوافدين الجدد
لتطوير غريزة الحفاظ على الذات لديهم.
لماذا قررت ترك مجموعة فاغنر التي
أخطط لها؟  اترك فاغنر لفترة من الوقت ولكن
لم تتح لي الفرصة كنت خائفًا من أن يتم
القبض علي وإطلاق النار علي كخائن.
أنا مستعد لاتخاذ إجراء جدي ولكني
أريد أيضًا أن أعيش في النهاية كنت أعلم أنهم
لن يسمحوا لي بالرحيل.  سأعود كجزء من
القتلى أو الجرحى، لقد حان الوقت
لاتخاذ قرار جذري لولا رفاقي ورفاقي
لكنت قد
دُفنت في بعض أماكن التدريب
كانت هناك
مزاعم وتقارير عن
إعدام مدنيين
مدنيين  تم إطلاق النار عليك أثناء سيرك في
الشارع لإساءة معاملة المدنيين، هل
رأيت أيًا من ذلك، هل شاهدت أيًا من
ذلك
أم
لا أستطيع أن أقول إنني شهدت هذا لأنني
كنت مكلفًا بشكل أساسي بمناطق الغابات
والأساليب المؤدية إلى باكموت، لست على علم
بمثل هذه الحالات لا  بغض النظر عن ما لدينا من
قواعد سلوك صارمة للمقاتلين، إذا تم
انتهاك هذه القواعد، فستكون هناك
عقوبة
هربت إليها إلى النرويج،
والمكان الذي عبرت فيه
حيث قلت إنك عبرت
إلى النرويج يخضع لحراسة مشددة للغاية على
الحدود الروسية
و  لقد أثار بعض الأشخاص تساؤلات
حول كيفية تمكنك من الوصول إلى
الحدود لأن الوضع مكتظ للغاية وهناك
الكثير من نقاط التفتيش على الطريق إلى
هناك،
لماذا أعبر من ذلك المكان حيث كان
يخضع لحراسة مشددة للغاية،
وسأقول أن الحدود مع النرويج هي المكان الذي
عبرت فيه  ليست محمية
بقدر الحدود مع فنلندا ولكن في
هذه الحالة أنا بصراحة ممتن جدًا
للتدريب الذي تلقيته مع
وزارة الدفاع الروسية حيث أديت
الخدمة العسكرية وممتن لفاغنر لأن
التدريب الذي تلقيته هناك كان
مفيدًا وأنا  استخدمها بكل سرور،
هل حصلت على مساعدة في العبور لأنه
لا يوجد الكثير من نقاط التفتيش حتى
للاقتراب من الحدود،
نعم لقد ساعدني العاملون في
مجموعات حقوق الإنسان في موسكو وأماكن أخرى،
حتى مجرد المدنيين الذين سمعوا قصتي
عندما كنت أقترب  آخر مشاركة
بجوار الحدود لقد ساعدني رجل
من ولاية فيرمونت حيث عثر على جواز سفر لرجل
يشبهني، وأنا
ممتن جدًا له ولكن لا يمكنني الكشف عن
هويته حفاظًا على سلامته، فقد ساعدني جواز السفر
في تجاوز المراقبة  قمت بالنشر
وتمكنت من الاقتراب من
الحدود
لماذا وافقت على التحدث لماذا ما هي
الرسالة التي تحاول القيام بها هل
تريد أن يعرف الناس عن فاغنر
عن تجربتك
كانت فكرتي هي إخبار الناس بما كان
يحدث هناك  وزملائي الذين ماتوا
هناك ماتوا بموجب أوامر،
لذا فإن هدفي هو
تقديم الأشخاص المذنبين بارتكاب هذه الجرائم
إلى العدالة وعندما تقول الأشخاص
المذنبون من تقصد وما
هو المذنب،
فنعم  كما تعلم، أود أن
أغتنم هذه الفرصة للقول
علنًا ربما يكون لدى الأشخاص الآخرين
وجهات نظر مختلفة حول هذا الأمر ولكن الجاني الأول
هو البروجوسيان لأنه
القائد الأعلى البروجوسيان الذي يدير مجموعة فاغنر
وهو المسؤول عنها،
نعم هو بالتأكيد وكل من
ينسق فاغنر  الكثير والجميع
يعلم أن الأمر يخضع
لأوامر الحكومة الروسية، كلهم
يفعلون ذلك ومن بينهم فلاديمير بوتين
جيدًا، الجميع يعلم أن ما
يحدث هناك هو قراره بالطبع
وأخيراً أندريه لقد خسرت الكثير
كما تقول زملائك
في القتال
ماذا يجب أن تعرفه أمهاتهم ماذا
يجب أن تعرفه عائلاتهم بشأن ما
حدث لهم، لقد
كانوا أشخاصًا عظماء عظماء لأنهم
كانوا بشرًا حقيقيين ويمكنني أن
أؤكد لكم أن الكثير منهم كانوا قضاة رصينين
لما كان يحدث هناك،
كانوا مجرد أشخاص عاديين وأشخاص عاديين  وهذا
ينطبق على الجانب الآخر أيضًا
لأنه أتيحت لي الفرصة لرؤية
شجاعة القوات الأوكرانية أيضًا. أندريه،
أقدر وقتك، شكرًا لك،
شكرًا لك